what I was gonna what I wanted to go
back really quickly to the Heimlich
because I was gonna tell you it was
timely on the story I read what my dog
ever tell you my dog got a ball caught
in her throat right and my buddy comes
running in my butt but he's throwing the
dog now my buddy's throwing the ball in
my dog Piggy and he comes running in
with my dog and he goes Brian I got
Brian I got he's [ __ ] dog swallow the
boy I can't get out of his throat and he
just throws on the ground he pushes the
dog at me because he's panicking he's
know what to do who's this my buddy Bob
okay he pushes the dog because and I go
and I go what's going on the dog gets
back up and then then basically looks at
me and keels over and dies his tongue is
out and I'm like what the [ __ ] is going
on so um I'm like the dogs dead and so I
picked the dog up and I try to shake the
dog and then he's trying to shake dog
now he's gotten to him he's reaching
into the bulldogs throat but the dog the
ball is a hard rubber and it's covered
obviously driver so he can't get his
fingers around and at one point he goes
ah he's shots and he's trying to get out
still won't come out I read I remember
reading so I finally go the dogs dead
let it go my heart's beating fast I love
my dog Oh dogs dead and he's going no no
I'm sorry I'm sorry back up so I go I
basically go I remember reading a book
as a kid called all creatures big and
small where he saves a colles life in
the back of a station wagon think that's
the story and he gives the collie of the
Heimlich from behind yeah so I take my
dog and I give my dog the Heimlich and
the ball [ __ ] comes out pull it comes
out here's the problem the dogs still
not breathing you know why there's a
bunch of dog food stuck behind the ball
cuz the dog threw the dog food up so now
we're shoveling dog food out but you
can't hind like a bunch of dog food
because it's all mushy and it's all the
way down esophagus or a down wind pot
whatever
so we're shoveling the dog and this is
probably I don't know man it feels like
two more minutes trouble yeah so to them
and so my friend clears and he starts to
blow he'd studied to be a vet you do
mouth to mouth you on the nose he closes
the mouth close their mouth and no
mouse to those that's what he's doing
dogs and he's screaming yep that's
exactly he do it you hold you hold the
dog's face and he's blowing on the dog's
nose on my dog Piggy adorable little pit
bulls and that star in the world you so
climb at its ear fell off its tail but
no that was Lucy my vote
Lucy wasn't that Lucy was piggy was the
dog before that rust-colored adorable
little the coos pitbull on the plan of
the earth and and I love that dog and
he's he's screaming Peggy because he
believes in all I said will you call
somebody back from the dead yeah he's
very spiritual he's in the boot voodoo
and my dog comes to comes to and it's
funny to watch how a dog comes to it
probably was anything a person the dog
went and farted and like a long fart
like and then you're and then hisses and
then you just my Darwin and for about
five ten minutes maybe was going still
out fill out oh really completely out
going yeah crazy high level of panting
and then finally comes to grabs the ball
all good and also all [ __ ]
hundred-percent good right so I'm on a
date at a place called buco
do you know Olympia Dukakis won an Oscar
for moonstruck look her up not your
generation but at one point she was an
Oscar winner okay I'm on a date with my
girl and uh it was kind of our first
date in fact when our first gate nope my
darling girls zet okay and yeah I don't
know if you remember her but she's great
she's very old yep okay so say 85 so
this is probably goddamn ocean golden
girl sure she was no she was in
moonstruck she was not a lot of stuff
she wanted Oscars okay anyways so uh I
basically I basically I'm on a date with
her I swear to god this is the
conversation she goes and I see Olympia
Dukakis come in and she's with another
couple and her husband and they're kind
of a they're at that point they're by a
sixty something Batman
they're back nine successful wealthy
well-dressed and she's a star at the
time she's my in fact my girls like
she's an actress she was holy [ __ ]
that's let me get to cos she's my
favorite actress great can't believe
that's Olympia Dukakis she can't believe
it and she's amazing and everything else
so blah blah blah she's like I well
don't look over there you know because
you know and and but Olympia is holding
court and talking and she's being funny
in the tables laughing long story short
my girl starts asking me what I would do
what I would do in an emergency if some
[ __ ] happened and I said you never know
I don't like to say that I would do
anything because I don't know until I've
been in the situation right
maybe I panic maybe I hope I wouldn't
hobo wouldn't be a coward I hope I'd do
something maybe see you know the woman
the woman talking at the table Olympia
Dukakis gets up and grabs her throat
Universal sign I'm choking and Olympia
Dukakis I think she goes cat she calls
her cat or something some name Cat Cat
and she can't answer and I remember I
saved my dog I look at her and I go are
you choking she's choking no he chose
she's just standing like that and
apparently you know you know fast twitch
muscle right burst oh not mostly fast
with yeah now you're so my frog legs
they spring into action
apparently what I did was I jumped over
the table I put a hand on table
chocolate huh okay I come in hot get
behind her your lady and I start to give
her the Heimlich and I tell her husband
I say stand up I bet she was I said Stan
because I want to hurt him to block her
because I didn't want the restaurant to
see her you know she's a distinguished
older lady yep yep and I kept a levar
I'm like I give it the old hon she was
hair like that and out comes the meal
now tell Amari a piece of meat out comes
a little piece of meat and I go you all
right no big day and I want to save her
from being embarrassed so I go you're
all right it's all good you okay not an
ugly deal and Olympia Dukakis looks at
me her hands go down like the traumatic
Wilma she she goes you moved like a cat
you're like a cat and she threw her arms
around me forcing
her friends life meanwhile I strut back
the whole [ __ ] restaurant sure girl
like this my girl my girl goes is a
phone steak and diksa
it's red painting I called her said you
saved a lot she called the sisters
because I just met my husband he's a
hero he saved
he saved like this my favorite I used to
enjoy this heroes heroes don't get me a
bit
well restaurant I did I did by the way
restaurant gave me that free bottle of
wine that's it should have paid my mail
what refer to me as the hero every time
I come back and know that I came back I
don't need free meal well hero should
get a free meal say huh me you a news
report zero amazing food too but now
they weren't given that out gave me a
free bottle one all the Dukakis didn't
give you a [ __ ] cowboy gave me take
they clap they clap for me as I left oh
we laughed for me as I left and you know
I'm as a hero I hang my head I don't
like a lot of attention as a fast twitch
muscle yeah right like hey hey hey
Dukakis I'm just called Dukakis you
can't bright my boy in the script saved
your best friend's life she is she had
already had her time at that point yeah
I want she should pull some strings
probably Gabey see right now let's give
this pilot girl that she would know you
know she wouldn't even recognize me but
I know she remembers the story you'd be
surprised it's pretty cool it was pretty
cool and at the point is that I moved
like a cat the point is I'm a hero point
is I spring backs boys I save your life
yeah life see that's what the takeaway
from this is a little dog's life and
save save a woman's life those two
things I got him an oxy and a fast
twitch you're a hero it's pretty good
day for the kale yeah and and pleased to
know and please know that I got I got
myself after I had mistake I got my dick
so yeah yeah at least uh-huh and she
said we going to anal she called us so
sorry I don't I just told the hero story
and you had to you had to talk about me
going in in South I'm a gentleman and
heroes don't go yeah you now that I
stayed alive I got a break in your ass
no you make love to a girl after that
you don't go alright I'm done with you I
don't know I'm not with your vagi vagina
let me break into that ass
is your first time let the here up
getting it that's so unhear oh because
I'm crabbing up and I'm okay hey I get
my reward
easy brother I was also older to her by
like ten years
gotta get in there I'm a hero let me do
it she's like I guess on the olive a lot
of ruining the [ __ ] a whole mood no
bro oh this is a special night you're a
hero
yeah we're gonna anal take a dicksuck
it's not staking oh no stake a D&E no oh
god damn it god damn it
it's Lobster little boy hey I look back
at that might get in the thumbs a girl
I'm getting their ass tonight I'm going
in south
cuz that's what heroes get after I
filled my belly with some boss in some
me I'm gonna take my I'm gonna take my
old dong breaking or a much younger
starfish no it's all fear that really
escalated I know what I do it's all
heroes do damn it's all no hero
man we made love beginning in the books
I only go ass to fill my belly and I
saved alive only go ass it's just the
rule it's decent dagger I don't know
what it is about saving lives but I'm
pretty turned on right now I'm thinking
I'm thinking your [ __ ] I gotta get in
the old poop chute that's how it is with
me I don't make love
Oh Mei yeah yeah well way to ruin that
story is right now yeah yeah yeah yeah
watch your tongue oh good
what's gonna happen what are you gonna
do use some of that boxing you've been
doing
[Laughter]